Here is the solution.
We start with the empty list. We go through all the elements in p.
This is the tricky line.
We will construct Q element-by-element by accessing the corresponding p,
and p is shifted by U and if this shift exceeds the range of p on the left,
we apply the modulo operator with the number of states as an argument.
In this case, it'll be 5.
Now, the reason why there is a minus sign is tricky.
To shift the distribution to the right, U = 1,
we need to find in p the element 1 place to the left.
Rather than shifting p to the right directly,
what I've done is I've constructed q by searching for
where the robot might have come from.
That's of course, in hindsight, from the left.
Therefore, there is a minus sign over here.
So think about this, as it's a little bit nontrivial,
but it's going to be important as we go forward and define
probabilistic convolution and generalize this to the noisy case.